is the third time really of the charm
for hillary clinton two democratic
operatives suggesting in a new wall
street journal op-ed that the failed
candidate may be the party's best choice
in 2024 but they were not the first to
float this idea that's right back in
december joe concha wrote she may be the
democrats best hope and joe koncha joins
us now with more for the trailblazer joe
are things really that bad in within the
democratic party that they're gonna dip
back into the clinton pool
well before i answer your question chef
guess let me be clear no one whether
it's shone or stein or me is arguing
that hillary clinton is a great or even
a halfway decent candidate or likable or
authentic or has any you know grounding
principles what we're saying here i
think uh particularly me and my column
on
december 15th is
it's kind of like if we're talking about
potential presidential candidates it's
like a conference in the nfl if that
conference was made up entirely of the
new york jets and giants okay so bear
with me for a second here todd right i
know you want to jump in hillary sees
these opponents and says well what would
really stop me from getting the
nomination if an 80-something joe biden
doesn't seek a second term and more than
a few democrats privately and even
publicly don't want him to do that at
this point here's hillary's conference
in the dnc division okay you got kamala
harris all right don't make me cackle on
that because she's at 32 percent
approval in usa today pete budage what's
he going to run on his performance as
the man who saved christmas or
performances fraternities are andrew
cuomo he's not available for comment
elizabeth warren how did she do in 2020
bernie sanders he was in college when
john f kennedy was president he'll be in
his 90s if he gets two terms if he
actually were to win gavin newsom stacey
abrams so yeah given all these versions
of the jets and giants why not hillary
as a democratic nominee but if you think
the aoc squad is going to embrace
another establishment relic from the
past well you've got another thing
coming buster so i think things are
going to get interesting as we approach
2024 and the president's poll numbers
continue to plummet guys
yeah to your point this is basically the
division of the jets giants texans
jaguars lions not a very robust
situation there quickly before we jump
to the second topic from a play-by-play
perspective continuing with the sports
analogy describe how 2024 hillary could
potentially play out
it could play out where joe biden now in
his 80s
is asked basically all right step aside
you you did what you're supposed to do
you made sure bernie didn't get the
nomination and donald trump wasn't
president now it's time to hand it over
to a younger hillary clinton who's you
know going to be 77 years old i think by
that point
uh so
at that point i would imagine that
kamala harris would make a run for the
nomination basically an open primary
right todd and it would be kamala and
maybe gavin newsom and then hillary
clinton and then hillary did get as many
votes as she did in 2016 she is the
established name and brand so why not uh
so that that's how i kind of see that
playing out that hillary just wins for
the sake of lack of a better idea yeah
you mentioned president biden's approval
ratings and a new quinnipiac poll has
met 33 percent approval on the economy
34 percent foreign policy 35 percent
coronavirus handling 39 percent what
stands out to you in those numbers
oh boy coronavirus pandemic 39 in that
same poll quinnipiac in may he was in
the upper 50s i think it was 57 percent
so i'm sorry he was in the 60s he's down
26 points uh from where he was so that's
a big big deal and look uh just one in
three americans supporting you after
year you wanted that's bad enough carly
right but when you peel back the onion
on this it gets worse just 25 percent of
independence support this president 24
of those aged 18 to 34 you know the
young people that propelled him to the
presidency uh 24 now support biden 43 of
democrats say they strongly support this
president so the base is very weak uh
and and he and by extension democrats
own 40-year high inflation supply chain
worker shortage
skyrocketing crime border crisis
embracing teachers over uh parents at
least teachers unions afghanistan
debacle and the civil war is only going
to get worse as this party stares at
what's coming at them in november carly
and todd that's right in november just
around the corner joe thank you so much
for joining us kinda
great to see you
guys
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now